[Music]
welcome to earbiscuits the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Rett and I'm Jesse W
this week at the round table of dim
lighting it's not link it's Mah it's my
wonderful wife
Jesse mlin I'm your wife uh you might be
a little bit confused because Jesse is
sitting where I usually sit which was
her request I don't really understand it
you don't know why can I tell you why I
did that yeah I will say you making me
feel a little uncomfortable that was the
point this was a power move okay you did
it because you know I'm the guest here
mhm although I have been a main
character for many years
oh uhhuh you yes I can't disagree with
that and you know you're comfy when I
was nervous about this you were saying
like don't worry it's not a big deal
it's nothing and yeah it's nothing
because you do this literally every day
um so do you are you saying that when
somebody is entering into a situation
where they might be a little bit nervous
it's not best I'm just minimizing I'm
just doing what mlin do we minimize
things if somebody if somebody gets hurt
if somebody dies if somebody is going
through something very difficult we're
like yeah but yeah I mean but look on
the bright side it's not that big of a
deal I just wanted you to feel a slip of
the discomfort that I felt yeah I'm I'm
not used to talking to people on the
right side of my face that's right and
so so you know it was it was a power
move and I'm proud of that uh do you
feel comfortable are you you good to go
I did I actually do feel much more
comfortable doing this knowing that
you're going to be here cuz you're going
to make me laugh well don't be too
soon and that is is going to make me
feel more like my myself instead of
being like a weird person that's on
camera the weird person part is fine we
were talking about that the on camera
part's a little tough well let's just
pretend M that we're just at our house
in our not in our
bedroom just let's just be in the
kitchen okay okay we're in the kitchen I
do I have my tea and we're just talking
you Jenna and this is like we find out
later that someone is taking the the
nestcam footage and putting it on the
internet but really we didn't know what
we were being filmed we didn't know what
these things in front of us were these
microphones do you know what I mean I do
but that sounds like it uh introduces a
whole other set of problems who is this
person in our
kitchen or with access to the cameras in
our house apparently it's actually
pretty easy to get access to to the to
the cams that's why when I'm at home um
I'm always acting as if I am on a TV
show have you noticed that I never say
or do anything at home that I would not
want captured for a reality television
show it's like I basically live my life
as if I am on Big
Brother and that's one of the things
that makes me such a great life partner
right totally
babes we asked you uh to ask us and
especially Jesse questions that we are
now going to go through uh so I mean
basically it was anything anything that
you wanted to ask and some are
voicemails some are tweets my fave do
you want to get started or would you and
I'm G to continue to call them tweets
let's just I'm not going to call them I
call them whatever the other thing is
yeah look you want to talk about how you
feel about that whole
thing I don't want to start this off
you're mourning the death the slow death
of Twitter am and it's been difficult
for me to be a just be a part of you
love Twitter so dang much you're so good
at it you really are really good at it
that's very sweet I don't think that's
true but I think I just care about it
more than you you understand it I like
it you just don't go to Twitter to look
at what people are saying about you like
I do I
like how and I guess this is really true
for any social media app but for some
reason it feels
especially true on Twitter that I can
look at like News
fashion find out like some celeb gossip
talk to somebody about their spiritual
what they're going through spiritually
like it's such a wide array like I can
follow scientists I just followed this
NASA female NASA engineer um you know I
that's
exciting yeah I and it's good for
somebody with ADHD but I will say uh you
you're kind of making your and I do
think that your Twitter experience is
rather sophisticated but I will
say um it is not
uncommon for you uh oh to show me
something from the internet often
Twitter and it's always very
sophisticated what I show you right and
super sophisticated stuff I would say
that high level big brain stuff I'm
showing I would say 25 to 30% of the
time the thing that you show me is
something that is amazing you that then
when you show it to me I'm like baby
that's fake
that is a lie that's not real I that is
a lie I thought no that happened once
that audio was put on there by somebody
happened one time I'm good at spotting
fakes I thought you were G to say that's
why I was laughing cuz I did not think
you were going to throw me under the bus
I thought it was going to be I think
it's wonderful I love that about you I
love being a to spot things that you
were going to say is that I show you
animals doing various things and I'm
like can you believe this animal is
doing this but sometimes you show me
fake animal things that's I think that
was like once like three years ago
anyway let's get to the question I love
the way you use the Internet thanks babe
it's very sexy yeah what did you tell me
you said recently you told me I was
showing you something you said I said
you're Amazed by a lot of things yeah
and you didn't mean it as a
compliment you said I was amazed by a
lot of things but it it felt like a
backhand compliment it felt like there
was a little jab in there no I like
being around someone who there's a sense
of discovery that is constantly sense of
wonder yeah it's a it's a sense of
wonder and I really appreciate it uhuh
how about we get started with a question
okay great um this is from Twitter this
is just a bell what do you find annoying
let's get started with that but secretly
endearing about the other
annoying but secretly endearing now I
had a tough time with this one oh I'm
sure you
did I don't find you annoying I I I
really enjoy your company we have a
really good time together we we like
dating one another we like traveling
together um but of course we've been
married for how many 23 two we're coming
up on 23 this year 22
years um and so of course I mean there
are things that that that
eventually uh may become annoying but
well you want to go first no I want you
to go first
okay and again annoying but secretly
endearing I just want to I want to
clarify
that
so when Jesse is talking on the phone to
someone okay you're gonna say okay so
just gonna sit over here and drink my
tea sometimes it goes like
this she gets on the phone and then all
of a sudden it's like oh no oh
no
oh oh I'm so
sorry oh
no kind of like that I'm probably not
doing it as well as she does it well
that's true and then I'm like who
died who died cuz obviously someone very
close to this person died or they were
in a horrible accident or they just got
a horrible
diagnosis and then you get off the phone
I'm like what happened and you're like
Christy stubbed her
toe and then other times other times
you'll be on the phone and you're like
oh no I'm so I'm so happy for you oh
that is wonderful that is so wonderful I
am so happy for you
oh that brings me a lot of
joy and then I'm like okay all right
somebody got uh somebody won the lottery
somebody got a promotion how many people
do we know that have won the lottery
none but I don't know but it seems that
way something incredible has happened
and then I'm like uh what what happened
and you're like Christy found her
keys um
so what I mean by this is that you are
so
expressive and you so empathetic on the
phone and in life in general that of
course you the thing that's annoying
about it is I feel like I'm I every time
you fool me every time I'm like what is
it what is it going to be and then it's
something rather insignificant which is
you know what the reason it's endearing
is because it's way better than not
being emphatic and
empathetic
emphatic and also this is not what I
give people when they talk to me on the
phone that is true if you're listening
to me talk on the phone it's like okay
either someone died or he's like
changing the nature of his cell phone
service I you know you you don't you
don't know what there's there's a lot
of I'm a
businessman Link's the boy I'm the
businessman so I keep it all business
when I'm on the
phone I um I have something things to
say about you being a business I think
that's again I think it's
wonderful I love the fact that you no I
and I think I end up uh
um I end up using this in the context of
our coupless because sometimes I'm like
okay somebody's telling us this in
person somebody's telling us something
right now that's difficult or great and
I just know that Jesse is gonna give
everything they
need and so I can kind of just
nod and it has handicapped me a little
bit I do believe I believe that
maybe uh when I when I have someone when
something happened to someone that's
good or bad and I'm only one there I
start panicking a little bit but I think
that was happening before I came on the
picture yeah it's not my family is not
great at this particular am not talking
about your family no no I'm just saying
that like
we we could be pretty stoic is what I'm
saying like you know um and so but we're
all learning we're all trying to get
better at it now what about me what's
annoying about me lots of things no one
thing I have realize that I'm just want
to preemptively apologize for is that I
am swiveling in this chair a lot I think
me having a swivel chair is probably a
bad idea it's making anybody nauseous
I'm sorry but it is soothing me um so
you know I think this is a common thing
mhm um we're driving in the car uh oh
you're driving yeah because you always
like to drive yeah uhhuh well I'd have
something to hold on to and steering
wheel I'm doing something on my phone
looking at amazing things on the
internet being amazed left and right or
being very empathizing with someone on
the phone and we drive past
something often an animal a cow or a
house or an getting a phone call I think
I am I turned my phone off well why
don't you answer and empathize with this
person show why don't we get a real time
demonstration of how good you can make
somebody how cared for you can make
someone feel God what what if you want
to turn your phone on do not disturb I
can I can do that should I get up and do
that this lady gets all kinds of phone
calls well if you empathize with people
you get she's a business woman she runs
her own business and she's constant L on
the phone we we took that trip to Big
sir we on the road for 6 hours you were
a business lady and things up over there
for 3 and a half hours I was like I got
to just sit here and listen to the one
side of a business conversation how the
turns have tabled
huh yeah I don't like to take my work
with me to Big
Sir you want me to turn my phone off or
not um I think it's fine I don't think
I'll get another call if I get another
call if you get another call we'll turn
off then I'll turn off okay
um what were you talking about okay yes
so there's something that in the uh
immediate environment that we're passing
that you think is
noteworthy yeah and you will say to me
look at
that but when you say it and I don't you
know I'm a slow processor I'm a little
bit of a slow processor I didn't play
like like basketball but I'm just asking
you to look at something no no no but
sometimes it takes me a second I'm not
asking you to comprehend it and then you
might there's a very specific spot so
you'll say look at that and I'll just
look at the first spot that I'm thinking
you're talking about but no there's a
specific spot an exact dis uh amount in
the distance that you want me to look at
and then you get very frustrated if I do
not look at it immediately and there's a
little bit of shaming had happening I
don't I don't believe that that that I
am not already in the
car looking at everything you're looking
at waiting for you to say I'm first of
all I'm driving I'm not do you also see
this but it might be look at that tree
that looks just like a
goat look at that no that one right but
maybe that's what you are looking at
because you're driving and that's an
experience for you and my experience is
might want share my experience well and
this is exactly why I find it see I've
I've reframed this
now
22 years into our marriage you know
there's that uh gotman Institute stuff
that I'm a big fan of about
relationships communication marriage MH
and uh they're the ones who did the
study where they could tell you within
like N9 minutes or seven minutes of
watching
couples talk I think sometimes it's like
film if they would How likely they were
to stay together MH and there's some
just
things ways in which we communicate that
like touching like this helps I mean I'm
sure that's nice I don't think that's
one of the
things if there's caressing like this I
do like it though then that means you're
going to stay together I like it when
you caress my arm let's not do that okay
so I've reframed this because one of the
things they talk about is is in
relationships are bids for bids for
connection
yes so it can be with your kids it can
be with your spouse it can be with a
friend you know when you say hey Jesse
look at that cow look at those cows over
there sometimes I just say cows right
right got a Shand sometimes I just say
the thing the implication is please look
at
it and and
I don't look up what you're actually
saying in that moment is connect with me
yes see what I see my love language is
is look at that that's
right and so now instead of being like
Oh my gosh he thinks what he's looking
at is the most important thing it's more
important than what I'm
doing I'm like wow He is wanting to
connect with me as he's driving down the
road mhm I get lonely over there
navigating navigating the world and you
do
business and I see things like we went
to Big Sir and on the way we passed the
Lavender Fields and then the lavender's
dead at this point but there's lots of
signs
about uh lavender tea and lavender gifts
P you were you were very interested and
enamored by the pistachios yeah Farm the
wonderful that's the we passed through
the wonderful pistachio farm and they
had
pistachios they had just trees and trees
and trees and then they had new places
that they were going little baby
pistachio
trees I'm just so fascinated by that and
you wanted to share your fascination and
it's the same it's actually the same as
me saying look at this
crazy giant squid right but I they found
but that's why I tell you about things
in real life because those pistachio
trees are not fake they were real it
very and and that's one of the ways we
know that they were real is we were
driving by them and so what I'm doing as
I'm trying to this this is not a bid for
connection I'm giving you someone that
they look at fake they show you things
that's not a bit for con you see those
trees they that's not photoshopped
that's real life and if you start
learning the difference between
photoshopped things and real life things
then nobody can dup you I'm just worried
about you getting duped okay if somebody
sends you a picture of me doing
something that's clearly
photoshopped you got to be able to spot
it this sounds like you're preparing for
some preparing me to get some kind of
bad pictures here's the thing is that
CGI and AI I know about and the conver I
know about AI because uh there was a
period where that is I know about AI
because I'm a person who lives in the
world and I read things you've seen a
movie too but there was also a period
where every date we went out on the only
thing that you would talk about is AI
and how concerned How concerned you were
and what we were going to do about it
and we're not going to do anything about
AI we are going to
be aied I haven't solved it in whatever
way that
means okay next question okay would you
like a to do a voicemail yes let's do
that we have that cap ability as
well hey Rhett and Jesse my name is Mia
and I've been married for about four
years coming up this November but um you
know we all know the secret to well not
so secret to a long lasting marriage is
communication loyalty all that good
stuff but I wanted to see if you guys
had any secrets for the little things or
silly things that you think has made
your marriage last so long and keep it
fun thanks guys bye so watch this I'm
going to do a kind of a cool
professional podcast thing and I'm gonna
say We'll answer that question in a
minute I'm just trying to I'm just
trying to impress my
wife uh but
first do you know about this I don't
know if you know about this well tell me
uh you do know that we're releasing a
cookbook yes I know about this yes so
this is something that everybody out
there in myth land has requested time
and time again when are you guys going
to have a cookbook I mean you're making
all these not us but Josh and the team
are making all these incredible recipes
when are we going to have a cookbook and
we're like well when we can do it right
you know how we do things at mythical we
don't like to be first we like to you
know be third or fourth and do then do
it right and um so the mythical cookbook
written by Josh with the support of the
entire mythical kitchen team this thing
of course features a lot of the fan
favorite recipes that we have enjoyed on
the show and then a lot of new stuff
that they have developed you know
they've been I mean it's like a lab over
there I mean it's like a kitchen but
it's like a very scientific kitchen yeah
you actually came home telling me how
good the cookbook was going to be and
how excited you were and how I am not
and how we were going to have to make
everything in the cookbook well because
I went to the photo shoot which was very
fun we did a really awesome photo shoot
the visuals in the cookbook are going to
be incredible and also the cover
I'm on I mean but so is Josh and so is
link and so is a lot of food and
um we had a lot of mythical people
inside this photo shoot but also just
the way the food looks we had to have
the food there and we were eating the
food in some of the shots and it's just
so good they do such a good job and now
you can do that at home and you can
pre-order this thing doesn't come out
until March of next year but you can
pre-order it so you will get it in the
mail as soon as you possibly can
it also helps with sales numbers if you
pre-order it so do that uh mythical.com
cookbook we made it very simple
mythical.com cookbook you can go over
and pre-order it right now and also as
we've been asking you lately if you
enjoy this podcast not just this
particular episode which I'm sure you
are especially this one because I have a
much better co-host this week um but if
you enjoy this podcast in general please
rate it and review it wherever you enjoy
it that's also very helpful
H ear biscus is supported by Rosetta
Stone you know why learning a new
language is so good well there's
multiple reasons link I don't know which
one you're about to say because it helps
you communicate with people who don't
speak ah yes the language the most
obvious answer yep y That's a good one
it's also really good for your brain to
learn a new language yes it can keep
your brain from Aging in comes Rosetta
Stone the most trusted language learning
program that truly immerses you in the
language you want to learn they've used
trusted experts for 30 years with
millions of users and 25 languages
offered including but not limited to
Spanish French German Korean Japanese
Dutch and Arabic it's built for fast
language acquisition having no English
translation so you really learn to speak
listen and think in that language and
it's super convenient with both desktop
and app options with audio companion and
ability to download lessons offline and
it's an amazing value as lifetime
membership has all 25 languages for any
and all trips or language needs in life
a $299 program but with our code you can
get it for just
$179 don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a very
limited time you can get Rosetta Stone's
lifetime membership for 40% off that's
$179 for unlimited access to 25 language
courses for the rest of your life redeem
your 40% off at rosettastone.com /ar
today see how I did that that was so
good did you find it a a little bit
sexy
yes thank
you okay Jesse do you remember the
question I do I got like a lock box in
there the little things not the obvious
things like communication and loyalty
boring what are the little things the
silly things that are a secret to a
longlasting
relationship you want to start or you
want me to I'm just teing it up for you
so many first of all I would like to
preface this by saying I like to preface
a lot of things because I don't want to
be
misunderstood I will not give advice
none of this is
advice I think that there are very few
people that I'm no there are a lot of
people I'm willing to take advice from I
shouldn't say that I just don't want to
be one of the people who gives advice I
will say what has been helpful in our
relationship okay every situation is
different thank you for couching that
yep in our
relationship I
think and this is actually I think this
goes back everything goes back to the
gotman
Institute of little
affirmations little positive things when
you come home from
work I always feel really happy to see
you and we usually give each other a hug
or a kiss mhm and it's a it weaves
positive interactions even if after that
I'm like this happened today or I'm
pissed or why did you do this and like
it started off in a safe positive place
and I think when there are a lot of
those when you have those in the bank um
it creates a level of comfort and trust
and
safety
H that was a great answer it almost
sounded like advice it not advice just
so you realize FYI no not advice
um uh I don't necessarily know if this
is well I'll ask you if you perceive
this as a good thing because sometimes
it might feel a little bit like a
an escape hatch from a difficult
situation but um well the nature and
I've talked about this on the podcast
quite a bit the nature of our
conflict um over the course of our
marriage
is re I don't know I'm just spitballing
here in terms of like as is compared to
the average couple probably high
frequency low
amplitude right there tends to you T
most couples tend to be on one side of
that sometimes there's like we never
fight but when we do you better watch
out or we have lots of little
disagreements but very rarely like a big
blow up which we're a little bit more on
that side which because we both kind of
speak our minds and so it isn't unusual
in a given week of interactions
for me to do something that makes you
mad right and I have found that if I can
make you laugh in in that moment it's
very helpful to
me yeah no I and I feel like it's it's
like the button that I push a lot I I
love that I think laughter is like one
of the most being silly we talked about
this recently how being silly is one of
the most healing things MH and I think
especially in the middle of discomfort
there's a way to be silly which is
bypassing an actual heart hard
conversation it's like not listening to
somebody I think you and I are at the
point where we're like I If if you're
being silly and it feels like a bypass I
would just say that but I think usually
it can just bring you back
to the love you have for that
person um and I think it most things are
not that serious like yeah I wouldn't do
this if it was like a real serious thing
right but there are times when I you'll
get mad about something and I'll do an
impersonation of you which might it
might it might seem it me saying that
might sound like it feels patronizing or
or minimizing well I think the thing
that's funny is I get mad and you kind
of like it yeah I kind of do you don't
you're not you're not scared of me
getting mad that has in our Rel
relationship we've always had like we
talk about stuff I like your passion we
talk stuff out and we sometimes but we
get very we get very real we do I'm not
trying to not make it
real anyway I so I don't know if that
again I don't know if that was advice
and if it was I don't know if it was
good advice I so well I mean it's when
your partner gets mad at you today laugh
at them or make them no make them laugh
that's it def it diffuses that sometimes
it can
laughter can diffuse if it backfires
though it's bad that's it's and and you
didn't tell them to do it if it you got
to know when to pull the
trigger okay
um this is a this this question is kind
of in the same vein but um the thing I'm
interested in is the second part of the
question okay so we can give a fresh
answer this is from validity
XP on Twitter uh after being married for
so many years how do you keep the
romance fresh or were there periods of
zero romance and how did you overcome
those periods of zero
romance do you recall any of these I do
fleeting moments I do I mean I think
we've had you know this
is in any
marriage there it's my mom would say
it's like the ocean you know there are
there they're waves and you kind of have
to learn to ride the wave
um and I love that because we have this
idea I mean I don't think anybody
actually has this idea that it's always
perfect but I think the longer you're
married the more you see that there are
it's kind of like
seasons and hopefully it it doesn't last
as long as an actual season does but I
do remember
specifically I think it was
okay uh as spent a lot of that year mad
at
you maybe it was 2017 going into 2018
I'm trying to I probably TW started in
2017 um that was the year you you were
working a lot yeah as was a rough year
and it there was a you had everything
you regularly
do GMM all of that but then you guys but
the GMM was the GMM 22 it was when we
were doing the five or five episodes a
day basically and for a really long
period of time we were shooting multiple
things every single day without without
pausing but then on top of that you were
writing a book you were
touring you were was it buddy system
also there was a buddy system season in
there it was any of those one things
would have been enough it was too much
and too much that was the year you
started having the thing in your eye
that World War II vets have where they
start Lo or they first saw it in world
world waral cus retinopathy yeah and uh
you started kind of your eyesight was
being affected couldn't see in the
middle of one eye right and but I had
another one
uhhuh and they said they the doctor was
like will you you need to reduce your
stress and um I said
you're going to
therapy yeah you
did and uh and so that had already begun
began that year uhhuh but then you were
on
tour it was Valentine's Day and you were
in
London and I was going through some hard
transitions with the kids going through
some stuff and I was eating like really
bad Pizza mhm London come on y'all and
uh it was a personally really
challenging time for me and it was
coming on the end of like a the year had
been challenging
before and you sent me a huge bouquet of
yellow
roses thank you for your
service this is this is I don't know I
might be I might be perceived as a [__]
after this or like as a spoiled I don't
know you can't do that but at that point
we had been married what 18 years 17
years and one of the
things that you should have known about
me and I think you did was that like I'm
not a huge flowers girl but I'm
especially not really a roses
girl double whammy uhhuh and it felt but
they were yellow and yellow I don't know
where yellow came from yellow is fine
yellow is not my favorite color yellow
is not you know well I'll explain in a
little bit okay so I it really just
gutted me you did not feel seen I did
not feel seen it wasn't like some
flowers might be some roses yellow roses
might be somebody's romantic dream you
know for me it was
like I'm feel like I've been holding
down the fort all year long with an semi
absent husband you were doing the best
you could but it was a
lot um
and he is not here on Valentine's
Day and not only is he not here he's
sending me something that you could
literally send to anyone on the street
like you don't have to know anything
about a person to send them these yellow
roses and in fact it kind of means you
haven't been listening at
all and so so it wasn't a romantic
gesture I did not feel romanced by that
gesture and we we I actually told you I
was going to talk about this because
this was a hard thing so I don't want
everybody like I didn't know okay um so
I'm so surprised you're sharing
this
I I think you called me I don't know but
I basically said I will speak to you in
a therapist's office oh and like I never
heard anything like that I will not
speak to you until then and you know I
am not a proponent of like game playing
if somebody's out of town and just
saying like I'm not gonna speak to you
but it was kind of a crisis point for us
maybe maybe we'll I probably have more
but that I feel like when I look back in
our marriage that was a really big point
because there was a way that we had both
been doing things me included I mean I'm
I am a pretty emotionally needy person
and I think I was looking to be have a
lot of my needs met in you and while
that's normal wanting your spouse to
meet emotional needs I
think I I wasn't doing the personal work
at least I hadn't been for some years at
that point I had started therapy you
been for a couple years figuring out I
was I was a newbie trying to figure out
what my own stuff was well and
I one of the things too and this is
looking back on that on that time
sometimes when you uh have
been uh I mean first of all we both have
been changing and growing over the
course of our entire lives right it
wasn't until it wasn't like oh and up
until we got to therapy like there was
no personal growth at all right but I
think
that sometimes when it comes to therapy
or anything that is beneficial for
someone's personal
growth uh you kind of lose perspective
they're like I don't know what's I don't
know what's changing about me I can't
perceive the change but when you tell
this story it definitely feels like
you're you're talking about a different
person right so first of all to further
contextualize it in your defense so
people don't develop this idea that it
was like oh I got the wrong gift and
then you said I'll only talk to you in a
therapist office which if you just take
a surface level analysis of this that
might be what you walk away with but the
reality was is that it was a very
difficult time um I was leaving you to
deal with a lot of things on your own as
it relates to our
family um there wasn't a lot of
connection I knew already that you were
having a difficult time I was having a
difficult time with being so busy and
then I'm I knew I was going to be you
know across the country on Valentine's
Day so I had plenty of time to prepare
and I think that you had set up an
expectation well this is an opportunity
again some people are like I don't
believe in you know
uh card company created holidays or
whatever I it was an opportunity to
express my love to you but more so
specifically to show you that I saw you
and appreciated you and then I did this
thing that did not communicate that so
now just very briefly in my defense just
give you a little bit of what I was
thinking so I knew you didn't really
really like flowers I didn't know that
the thing I knew you really didn't like
was potted plants because I made that
mistake really early in our marriage we
get getting you a very unromantic now I
would probably prefer a pot of plant
flowers but um but I knew you didn't
really like flowers a whole lot and I
knew you didn't really like roses that
much but when I went to the website for
this place yeah because it was
definitely a website you did not go in
person anywhere anyway go ahead yeah
right there at the top of the website
there was this incredibly impressive and
it wasn't that it was a bouquet of roses
it was that they had somehow
put the roses into a sphere a the
spherical shape have you seen this thing
it's quite
phenomenal it's not a bouquet it's like
there's a there's a thing on the bottom
and then they've create made the roses
into a and it looked bigger on the
website than apparently it was no it was
big it was really it was a bhere it was
a big sphere of something that I did not
like right right right no but I'm just
telling you I I'm sure it was expensive
I'm G I apologize and I will get back to
it but I'm just telling you I wasn't a
complete ding bat I was sort of like
this thing is very impressive and I
think you have to use roses to make this
thing and so I got I got to the place
where I was focusing on the wrong thing
and I quit seeing it as a bouquet of
roses and saw it as a flower sphere that
was very impressive to me personally
which I know what I'm getting you for
Valentine's Day and I thought that you
would like this Rose
basketball and that you would be like
impressive love baset it was like one of
the more things there so I was like well
this is and then the reason I got yellow
is because um I was like well getting
her the red ones I know she doesn't
really like roses but most roses are red
but if I get her yellow roses maybe
they'll pass as something else in this
sphere it was I'm not I'm just telling
you I shouldn't have done it but I mean
there there was a convoluted thought
process there are much worse things I
think it was emblematic of where our
relationship was there's a million
different things could have done yes and
also there's a million different things
I could have done uh leading up to it to
show my care so anyway um what I ended
up doing was we like we did not talk on
the phone for maybe three days while I
was overseas which was highly unusual
for us to not touch Bas every single day
if we're tra if I'm traveling you know
we have our little check-in and um then
I was like kind of scrambling cuz I was
like what am I going to do what am I
going to do dud I can't make her laugh
from over
here you know so I ended up finding a
cool shirt you did you went to a vintage
store and got me a shirt that I loved
and still have I mean the shirt didn't
fix it wasn't the shirt that fixed it
that was the we ended up having a a
session a few I think at least one yeah
that was actually we had some
breakthroughs and I think one of the
breakthroughs was
uh we were both already having
individual breakthroughs and that was
one of the things that my therapist had
said early on when I talked about some
of
our marital the things that we struggled
with was that he felt like it would be
more beneficial in the beginning for us
to work on our own individual issues and
that that would spill over into the
marriage and um I kind of didn't believe
him that seemed crazy to me and it was
true um and I think the benefit
for me was that for both of us was that
we were both working on things
individually um I think it it would have
to be really hard to be in a
relationship where you know only one
party was willing to do the work um
because it's hard
and there are many days where I say like
I feel like I've grown enough I don't
feel like I need to grow anymore I'm
tired I just want to get in bed I don't
want to face the stuff inside of myself
that
is gross or is Scary or um but anyway
having somebody who is also doing the
work and looking at at the things that
um things that are challenging or the
things that are hard and I mean you did
that like one of I think one of the big
epiphanies that you had during that time
is we had always had this idea
that when hard things were happen
happening in our you know in our little
family um or with me that somehow work
also happened to be really busy and that
was just weird how that happened it
always synced up like that and then I
think what you saw is because work is
something you're really good at and you
know how to do you would actually maybe
Retreat into work um instead
of face the things that that were're
hard in our
relationship um because kind of like
what we talked about earlier maybe the
emotional um plane is one that can be a
little more challenging for you um I
don't think that's true anymore like I I
really when you say you feel like that
was a different person I kind of feel
that way
too um because I think the way that you
have in the past few years done so much
work to
be able to be present emotionally and to
be vulnerable even though that's a hard
word for you to say I don't say it the V
word um
vulnerable I say it
[Laughter]
wrong uh but it is hard to imagine that
specific scenario
unfolding for a number of
reasons I mean first of all I just know
I'm never going to get you a Rose
basketball again like specifically I'll
never do that
again but
also I think
that um well practically speaking link
and I have gotten better about not overc
committing to things yeah um we still
work very hard but it's not just a
maddening amount of things all at once
and it was there was a couple of years
there 2017 might have be the Pinnacle
yeah of just the number of things that
converged um well and I think I've done
work around like I do think gift giving
is a big thing for me and because I
really like to give gifts and and I
think because our relationship felt
challenging in other ways I was I was
putting all of this expectation around
whatever gift you gave me that that
would somehow be a way that you saw me
and like giving gifts is not easy for
everybody and you know
people some people don't care you don't
really care about gift giving and so I
think as we've worked on the other parts
of our relationship and they're more
secure I also am not needing the gift
that you give me at a Holiday to be it's
not a test it's not a test that I'm try
I'm supposed to pass or whatever and it
wasn't then
either but yeah and I and I think that
we're just a lot more on the same page
right now and a lot of it has to do with
the fact that it does have to do with
the fact that we're in therapy and so
and then we talk to each other about the
things that oh what did you what did you
talk about in therapy today and we kind
of we have a different kind of
connection our connection is stronger
and I kind of feel like I I know where
you're at in any given time more so than
I
did six years ago for number of
reasons um but enough about that let's
talk about my music
career
uh one question and because uh in very
rewarding ways my little venture into
James and the shame has been able to
involve you and been a way that we've
been able to work together in a way that
we always kind of wanted to but never
had worked together mythical Miss B says
what is your this is for you what is
your favorite James and the shame track
from Human
overboard and will we get to hear you on
the new
EP when does this come out what what
what date does this come out Jamie uh on
10 n okay all right okay
so yeah so yeah so at the end of this
week okay yeah all right so we get we
get to talk a little bit about something
here or you do well my favorite track is
the last song on human overboard it's
not the one that's about you I sing I do
love that but that seems kind of like
ego maniacal if I say
that um and I also love the one about
our kids but the last song that you also
sing on yes uh letters old letters old
letters um I Cry Sometimes when I listen
to that
song because I
think it just really
encompasses the person you were and the
person you are and how they're very much
the same
person and
not the same person at
all um and I think you know you kind of
went through
that little bit of an angry atheist
phase
uh early
on
and I think anytime you go through any
kind
of spiritual or major like paradigm
shift often you do kind of go people go
through an angry phase
um and I don't think all atheists are
angry so I'm not this is not saying if
you're an atheist you're angry I do not
believe that but I think yours was
specifically stemming from just some of
the pain that you were dealing with um
and I think as you've gotten further
from
that there's I think for both of us
there is an openness more of a spiritual
openness um and more of a peace and less
of having a view on things that is a
reaction to an old View and more of a
like what where am I right now as
opposed to you
[Music]
know what am I reacting against because
of where I was and I think old
letters it ends with that openness mhm
and sometimes that makes me
cry well thank you for saying
that um and we will hear you yes on the
new ep the song that comes out uh if
you're listening to this on the week of
October 9th I think it's the 13th is
that right is that what I said it comes
on on the
13th is
um is a song all about you you don't
sing on that one actually I did a six
song EP and two of the songs are about
you so pretty good it's probably a
little
excessive kind of excessive 33.33 3 33%
of my songs on this album about you we
had a seventh song that we were sing
singing together that we just never
quite cracked and time ran out that will
probably be on something in the future
but uh the second song that would just
be a part of the the EP is about you and
you do sing on it and you sounds so good
um but it's funny because the song I
talked about this at some point on a
previous year biscuit when I was talking
about the songwriting process and how
sometimes things come sometimes songs
come very very quickly almost fully
formed and the song the one I love to
find that comes out
Friday uh was based on an experience
that we had together of me kind
of finding you and saying that you're
the one I always love to find and
then realizing as I said it oh that's a
good country song I think I actually
said that I think I told you that sounds
like s okay all right well you made it
seem like it was my thoughts and uh and
then we and then we got I got back home
and the song like came to me f fully
formed like basically Melody and first
first chorus like like in the shower and
it's like okay I'm just singing this
song and then got out of the shower
clothed myself and wrote the song and so
that one's for you it's about you but I
wanted it to be very like this is just
my thought about you given to you so I'm
not going to ask you to sing on it it
just had a purity to it it's really
sweet but I but I've enjoyed working
with you in that capacity and also us
like you know getting to perform
together like we did at at mythicon no
it's been it's been a nice it's been a
big nice and big thing that's very
descriptive a nice and big thing for me
uh to I don't know I've I've had to deal
with a lot of like my performance
anxiety you know I was a music Major and
and performed as a kid a lot and was a
little theater kid and then as an adult
kind of retreated and didn't do a lot of
that and so um it's been I think healing
for me to revisit that in a different
way in a different space and and figure
out how I relate to that part of
myself well I've had a lot of fun with
you I had fun with you thank you for
asking me and saying about for saying
yes
um okay let's do another Twitter
question I'm turning this is from Sam
I'm turning 40 in February and it's
freaking me out not so much the getting
old part but the running out of time for
things part I feel like my church
background made me miss a lot of things
so I guess my question is what advice do
you have for wh ifs of turning
hey Sam I think I met Sam at mythicon
okay I love this question because when I
turned 40 I had a mini existential
crisis for sure it was
2020 um you know the last year we had
spent in the house with Co everybody was
in the house for most of that year not
us specifically um but I
just it was like I could not accept that
I was going to 40 this thing that had
always seemed
so far away was upon me and I didn't
know how to deal with it um well and
when we were growing up L and I were
talking about this the other day when uh
our parents or our parents friends
turned 40 they would do the ly ly right
Diane's turning 40 party which had the
over the hill cake
everything yes the funeral right totally
it's like I mean listen we were in the
south in like the
80s so people would be dropping left and
right in their 40s but I
mean that doesn't happen anymore well
that happens that does still happen but
I do think not old 40 is not old and I I
do think that like we have a different I
don't know we think of of adulthood and
and of Aging differently we used toh but
I do think that there is a lot to be
said
for grieving what could have
been
um and that can be in in any in tons of
there's tons of examples of this whether
it's like a job that you maybe could
have had that you didn't or a
relationship or children or a house that
you love that you
missed out on or whatever um and I I
think that process for
me because I definitely relate to that
you know I
mean I took a very specific path based
on the culture that I was in and what I
thought I had always wanted you know I
was a homeschool mom um I
was moved across the country to support
my husband's career like it was a
very uh others
focused first part of my life and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that like I think that's beautiful and I
think it there comes a point where
you're like man do I know myself did I
miss out on me what are the things I
could have been doing that I didn't
do um and so I think well because in
in the culture that we come from
um a woman deciding to pursue some of
those things that are her
interests pursue her dreams her follow
her curiosity those things are deemed
selfish well and I don't think a lot of
times those things that are I'm not I'm
just saying right I don't think it's
true acoss nobody gets mad at the man
for following his curiosity right and uh
so I had to I think allowing yourself
that time to grieve like it's one of
those things that there's no way around
it you just have to go through it and so
really giving yourself the time and the
space to be like man this is hard I am
sad
I I don't know what that life
was that could have been like the
country song What Might Have Been I
don't even like country music except for
James and the shame um
but the flip side of that is you know
you don't know what hard and tough and
bad things happen that you could have
happened that you missed out on too so
that works that goes both ways um and
then the other thing I like to think
about is
that I'm as young as I'll ever be from
here on
out and you know that great poet siza
says half of us Chasing the Fountain of
Youth and it's in the present now and
like I'm young I'm
42 a baby and I'm a little baby and when
I you and M 90 this was a I was
listening to a podcast recently and they
were giving tricks it's hidden brain
they were giving tricks for
savoring how you Savor the present and
how we make our life last longer um and
how we motivate ourselves to do things
that sometimes we don't want to do and
and one way is to play a trick a Time
trick on our mind and to pretend that
like we are our 90-year-old self my
90-year-old self is is gets the chance
to come back and sit at this table with
you I use this right
now yeah yeah I've used it before too
but it was very confirming to hear it in
this podcast but like how if if
90-year-old Jesse was in this body right
now
what would I would think I'm young and
vibrant and I would think I had the
whole my whole life ahead of me right
and so moving forward I just want to
savor the moment and be excited about
the
possibilities that is a great answer
there's very little to add think about
the what now not the wha
ifs um how about another voicemail I'm
going to make you stick around for a
little a little bit because we don't get
this
opportunity very often to talk to you
so hey red and Jesse my name is Sandra
from Jersey I love GMM and ear
briskets okay so I was raised in a very
religious household I went to 12 years
of Catholic schools followed by four
years at Catholic college should be
noted around 10th grade I personally
stop being religious although I was
still in that lifestyle until I
graduated college my question for you
guys is how do you navigate family
members I honestly I get so angry
sometimes I just want to go into it with
them but they're not listening and I'm
just making myself sick with anger or
what have you I want to respect their
beliefs but they refuse to to respect
mine but I still want to be the bigger
person and not let it get to me so is
there any advice that you would give me
cool thank
you you want me to go or do you want to
go why don't you I like listening to you
talk I I think I would broaden this
question to
just include talking to
anybody that we disagree with or that is
coming from a different place than us it
doesn't have to be family um it could be
friends it could be neighbors obviously
anyone that has a different perspective
um and especially now I mean we
are very very polarized in this country
um and it's something I think about a
lot lot and I fail at a lot is talking
to people
who see the world differently than I do
um and you know I talk about it in
therapy a lot I am I like to think of
myself as like passionate and
fiery and my therapist has used words
like
combative
and uh I don't know that he said
aggressive but similar words
um and so it's been interesting for me
to be able to kind of step outside of
myself and and see that part of me
because I always kind of thought I was
like this very this rule follower who is
very submissive and that is in me and
then this whole other person is in me
too who's like down to debate um and you
know when I was an
Evangelical um that looked looked a very
specific way and I think I have kind of
um just transferred some of that passion
now to the other
side um and so I've been taking that
apart a lot in my own work
and questioning why I do that and why
does it sometimes do I come away from
those conversations I had a conversation
last week with a guy not a family member
but a guy um that you know we disagreed
on some pretty big things
and
I can often come away from those
conversations feeling like they were
pointless or they actually did more harm
than good and while sure it's great to
stand up for for what you believe in and
I
think people have to you know it's
really important to me to stand up for
marginalized people or for
Injustice um but there is a way to do
that that as my mom would say she uses
this phrase and I love it takes a chunk
out of you um sometimes we get into
these debates with people and you walk
away feeling like wounded
wounded um and so one thing I'm working
with I mean the biggest my
biggest biggest thing I would say about
this is like I'm the
problem and when I'm in these
debates they like Signs pointing me back
to the stuff that I have to work on in
myself um if I'm triggered by something
somebody says and things are triggering
people say triggering things but I think
the more grounded and healthy of a place
I am the more I'm able to
like actually listen and actually be
curious and see that person as um the
way that I want to be seen I don't want
to be seen as a set of ideologies and
beliefs like I want to be seen as a full
person with hopes and dreams and a
history and uh wounds and you know who's
trying to grow but who's [__] it up a
lot um but I I want there to be grace
for me as a person who is also able to
change and I hope I keep changing I hope
I keep growing I hope I don't get so
stuck in any of my ways that I can't see
myself and others for who they really
are so I think for me when I have those
conversations I'm trying to get better
at really being curious
and seeing whoever I'm speaking to as a
full three-dimensional
four-dimensional person I don't know how
many dimensions we're in who um who is
worthy of of love and respect and is
deserves to be
heard well said and I think that you
know for me and you obviously it's not
like we are um it's not the same as if
you are a if you are a marginalized
person if like if you're a queer person
and you're having a debate with your
family trying to legitimize your own
existence or a relationship you're in
your
identity that's a very personal thing
right but
for uh most of the conversations
especially a conversation like if I'm
having a conversation with somebody I
don't check any of the marginalized
boxes right I don't know if long hair
and beard is one of them but I don't
think it is not it is not maybe really
tall that's no that is not that's an
asset all right so I don't check any of
the marginalized boxes please so Lord
any debate that I get into about any of
these hot button issues that everyone
wants to talk
about um what I the the thing that I'm
thinking in the moment is like you think
me and you are going to solve like you
and me whoever you might be you think
we're going to solve this issue right
now and do you and actually do you think
that that's what this conversation is
about because most of the time it feels
like an argument is about two people
trying to justify their own their own
beliefs right they're not really
interested in changing their mind and so
and usually there's a fear behind a very
passionate belief it's like what do you
like what are you really what are you
actually scared of that drives the
passion about this particular thing and
I mean I think I think you have to be
careful and it's a very fine line to
walk between using like that as an
excuse to not engage in ISS and I this
is what you're saying um you know that
we're not going to solve it but I think
there's some humility in that that is
what you're getting at that is like
coming to any of these issues
realizing that we aren't we aren't going
to solve it don't get me wrong this
doesn't keep me from debating these
issues I can't help it if somebody
brings something up but I try to see it
in a different way and be like okay well
um I actually think he would be more
fruitful to make a connection to make a
connection right because um if we if I
can say let's not talk about this exact
thing right now is there a per is can I
ask you a personal question can I ask
you about something that's going on in
your life
because if our relationship ends up
boiling down to our difference in
opinion on this thing then that becomes
the subject of most of our
interactions that's not a
relationship so we need to have a
relationship so we can develop mutual
love and respect so that then we can
maybe have a fruitful discussion about
something that is actually like seeking
to understand the other person not just
trying to go into the defensive and
again I say in this say this as someone
who's not I'm not trying I'm not
defending I'm not being oppressed I'm
not defending anything so but and I will
say when I get into these debates my MO
is going to be to try to identify where
the power imbalance lies and where the
marginalized person is in this situation
and root for them that typically you end
up being right most of the time I think
if that's your if that's the way you
follow these things but well I think too
you know as we talk about this in
therapy that energy is it's such a like
whatever woo idea but yet continues to
be true in my life my sister and I
always talk about how energy doesn't lie
and you know when the energy behind me
debating someone to be right which I
have done much of my life and continue
to do and I'm actively working on not
doing it that way and failing I'm
working on it and failing but the energy
behind that is very different from the
energy behind seeking to understand the
energy behind seeing somebody as a
project whose mind you have to change is
very different from like seeing somebody
as this full person who's worthy of Love
even if you
disagree um and so I I do think when you
look at the people who have made the
most strides
in Justice Arenas you know or the people
people who are doing these incredible
people who are serving people um often
they are the most grounded
people because they know how to uh how
much energy to give and and when to to
preserve their
energy and um so that's something I'm
just I'm thinking about more and failing
at
and and I think it's a great thing for
us to talk about because well I've seen
you exercise this in real time and
I'm uh I think you're doing an
incredible job let's do one more kind of
serious one and then one really fun one
like we're taking photos and we want to
do a fun one to end on so everybody goes
home feeling good about themselves but I
never feel good about myself for those
fun pictures I always am like I don't
know what to do okay well you're going
to feel good about this one okay so um
this one's from
Kyle what was the exponential rise in
popularity for GMM and mythical like for
Jesse were there any sudden life changes
due to the fame and what was adapting to
that new lifestyle
like
interesting
Jesse I don't think there were any
sudden I mean I guess the most Sudden
Change would be moving to La all those
years ago that's it all fell apart
uh but when we lost our
way I do think something that I've H am
have had to learn how
to work with and am continuing to learn
how to work with is uh dealing with
criticism not for myself but mostly like
for you and for
link
um you know
there is I think we both would say this
is like I feel I feel all the time so
blessed so grateful
so thankful and lucky and just happy to
be able
to be on this ride with
you to walk alongside you as they used
to say to do life with you what other
bad um analogies can I metaphors anyway
get on the horse with me yeah
um but I think it's one thing that is
challenging is seeing everything that
happens behind the scenes and then
seeing somebody log on and criticize a
decision that you spent so much Blood
Sweat and
Tears trying to you know coming to or uh
and this isn't I'm not talking about
like moral failings I mean that's not
not that your deconstruction was a moral
failing it was the ultimate moral
failing what are you talking about J
that that was challenging in its own way
and I that's kind of even separate from
this maybe connected but you know it's
like let's you change a logo or you
change whatever nobody said anything
about that
and I you know it's like
you're often
eating and sleeping and breathing these
things maybe not for the logo change I
don't know maybe that was a bad example
but you have put so much thought and
energy and there's so many even other
people and PE you know there's so many
different elements that come into the
making of some of these decisions and as
your wife and as somebody who loves you
and has a lot of respect for for you
it's just really really hard to see
somebody say that you to uh assign
negative motivations to those things and
I think like that's such a small thing
to have to deal with but it's hard
because often as your wife I do want to
jump in and say something and I don't
don't get into the fry Jesse I do not
and I'm pretty could it not but I think
that continues to be something like I
want to defend you I I want defend and
you letting me vent to you when I get
home and we do our little hug and kiss
and then I immediately start ringing my
hands um it's funny because I uh I was
thinking about this exact thing in
relation to uh you know it's football
season right now I watch football I
watch college football and uh did you
see Taylor Swift well that was NFL okay
oh Travis plays for an NFL team well
yeah wonderful you said you watched
football I'm not much of an NFL fan but
yeah I'm all about the what what is that
couple name called now I don't know do
they have a couple name cuz his name is
Travis and her name is yeah I don't
think it's been decided as of this
recording okay but yeah this will be old
news by the time this comes out they're
call something very specific or or oh no
we're all going to be invested we or
they may be broken up they may be broken
up invested NL tor's version I have
never cared about the NFL until now ever
I proba all not to burst your bubble but
this is probably no she was having fun
did you see her she was having fun she
was eating her little chicken strip with
the seemingly Ranch I love yeah I don't
know what you're talking about um but
back to college
football the real deal you know uh I
follow NC State football because I went
to NC State and uh I'm a big wolf pack
fan another word I'm not great at saying
unfortunately that's our
mascot and you know like people just
criticize uh the coach you know after
even after like he wins a game uh the
way that he goes about it and then the
conversation gets so toxic
and it's it's funny because I'm not
coaching a college football team you're
not and uh it's not like once a week we
either win or lose that sucks you know
that sucks like I have a Content stream
and it's like very subjective and it's
just like is it going to get views and
we're going to make other decisions like
logo changes or events or changes to
services or all the you know hundreds of
decisions that we make in a year about
specific things that people
enjoy and uh but the thing that I always
say is and I actually think this applies
to you know it's funny to get back into
the polarization political polarization
in our country since we haven't talked
about that enough um there tends to be
this idea that people on the right are
patriotic and people on the left are not
patriotic but actually like when you are
a fan of a team you tend to be pretty
damn critical of the things that that
team does because you love that team you
are invested in that team and so tend to
take the investment that people have in
what we're doing and the things that
we've built I even when it gets critical
I tend to say you know what I'm going to
choose to see this person's concern
about this particular thing that we have
done I'm going to see that in the light
of them actually really really caring
about the things that we do and it's a
privilege to have anybody that's healthy
that's a healthy way to look I'm I'm I'm
not I'm not he as healthy as but I will
say the thing that the part that really
gets in my girdle is uh where's your
where's your girdle it's just it's just
it's a figurative girdle that I wear at
times that keeps my tummy in so I don't
to think about hold expression it gets
your goat I I just invented a new I like
it okay and uh is when they
assign intention right negative
intention oh they're doing this
because flagrant assumption about our
character or the way that we see right
our fans or whatever that's the part
that is upsetting it's like well okay
I'm not going to get into it I can tell
you all the reasons that we made this
decision but I'm I like the fact that
you care I don't like the fact that you
assume why we made this decision and
then begin spreading this idea but I can
live with it it it comes with the
territory but I really appreciate the
fact that you care because I do
think you know uh like you said we are
hashtag bless
is that still a thing no um I'm bringing
that back
too it really gets in my girdle that we
don't use hashtag blessed
anymore and we
have all of our needs are met and most
of our wants are
met It's like got nothing to complain
about uh but that doesn't mean that
there aren't difficult things
that I face or you face that you you
still want somebody to commiserate with
you know and I appreciate you I'm a good
Coomer there for that because again you
oh tell me
more
no I really like that about pretty sure
I don't sound like you don't do that to
me as much as you do it to your friends
uh but I'm not asking you to I'm not
asking you to exaggerate your your
empathy for me I I you do it just right
do you want to end on a fun one sure
um okay this is from fast acting
glue not a brand not a sponsor just a
Twitter handle if you had to eat a
stick and this is not a sexual joke I
didn't do this to set set up a sexual
joke
okay if you had to eat a stick would you
microwave SL steam it or eat it
[Music]
raw I
would we just got this not a sponsor but
we got those what are those pans is that
what they're called any day any day it's
David changen right yeah they're the the
they were on Tik Tok and somewhere else
in there
the you can mic these
microwavable it's a glass container that
looks like Tupperware but it's glass and
it's uh with tops it that look like they
have some aluminum but they can release
they they release a little steam in
certain pressures they don't pop off and
you can cook anything in these things
it's crazy they should be a sponsor
because you can turn your and I think it
is David Chang I think I'm right about
that right because he was doing this on
Tik Tok where he's using these glass
things to make his family food and he's
like putting like salmon in the Micon
you can cook salmon in them like are you
sure you can do that you can we have we
have it's delicious and yeah would put a
stick in that with a little like Lowry
seasoning salt oh yeah back to the stick
I forgot that's what this is about we're
talking about the stick got get put a
wet stick in
well little twig boy should be all about
microwaving some wet sticks right well
again I didn't think that this was going
to get sexual but the little twig boy
the little twig boy is not expecting the
forest Queen to eat his stick like
that's not I'm just saying that's
not not I'm are we are we going to dress
up his little he is expecting that but
that's not what this is
about he doesn't have to expect it we
don't even have to make it about that
can we go to Rex now I have some Rex Oh
I thought you've been the hospital where
our kids were
born Rex Hospital um that would be a
long trip okay uh yeah so do you want to
do that like if we talk about it now
we're going to have to do it dress up as
the farest queen and the little twig boy
as our Halloween costume I don't know
what else we were going to dress up as
so I think it's a great I love when
people give me Halloween ideas costume
ideas such an inside joke though like
but that's that's what makes it fun well
never make it into People magazine with
that we won't be next to Heidi in in her
worm costume I don't think that I don't
think that's what's keeping us from
making it uh no uh okay I don't know
what the I can imagine what the forest
Queen would look like I've got some
ideas the little twig boy little twig
boy needs some like leader hosing but
the little twig boy remember is the Big
Bad Wolf but it's just a big bad wolf
well you know it's just a boy pretending
first Halloween together you dressed up
as big bad wolf dressed up as grandma
it's full circle and I was Little Red
Riding Hood yeah it's pretty
close so we can dig those
up but back to eating the
stick I think what I would
do um I don't want to make this not fun
anymore but I would grind it down into
dust and I would slowly insert it into
soup over the course soup was not an
option I don't he didn't say anything
about soup or she no I technically I
would eat it raw but it would be used as
a thickener in soup and it would go
unnoticed it would be F I would enjoy I
think you're cheating I mean I did add
some Lowry seasoning salt but I don't
think that that's cheating I think soup
putting it in soup well I would put it
in a cheesecake then okay well it's you
can't just put put a stick in a
cheesecake you got to make it I would
make it sawdust um Jesse it has been so
fun having you here at the round table
for having me can I sign it I do I get
to sign it well we don't really do that
anymore but yes okay we're breaking all
kinds of traditions we don't really have
guests anymore but yeah you've never
signed this table so we need to make
that happen um but I would like to you
said you had two wrecks oh I do I have
two wrecks we've already wrecked any day
Tupperware
stuff uh our dear friend Jacob actually
wrecked this book to me
um and it is called your brain on
Art it's by Susan Magnuson and uh Ivy
Ross Ivy iy Ross Ivy Ross and uh it's
exploring
what art does to our brain and how
necessary it is it's bad for is it I
knew it was bad for it dang it it is
fascinating and there's this whole new
field of study called uh neuro Arts
neuro art I believe and it's it's
basically the study of of what art what
being in
nature uh even doodling what all of
these things do to our brain and it's
amazing and confirm
and
exciting your brain on art is that your
only recck or do no I have I have well I
have lot we could do recks forever but
okay well you need to give these to me
so I can do them I just finished a
podcast called
girlfriends and it is I'm not I don't
listen to a lot of True Crime I you I
like cult podcast I like scam podcast
42y old lady talking about a true crime
podcast this is is this is such a cool
podcast it's about a um woman who went
missing in New York in the
80s and all of these incredible women
who came together to convict
her uh plastic surgeon
husband um but it deals with like it's
always the plastic surgeon uh domestic
violence and um it's really really
beautiful tribute to women who have
um been murdered or been abused through
domestic violence but it's also weirdly
um an amazing look into these women's
lives and and there is a lot of laughter
and the music is incredible in fact the
music was so good that was composed for
this podcast that I downloaded the music
on Spotify um but anyway I just I love
it I think everybody should listen to it
the girlfriends y um and speaking of
listening to music I will take this
opportunity to plug the song that's
coming out this Friday and the second
single off of the upcoming James and the
Shane EP this one's all about you and if
things go according to
plan which at the time of recording none
of this is finalized so this is a real
risky thing to throw out there um I
ideally the physical
album the vinyl the CD and the cassette
along with some special merch for this
EP will all be available for pre-order
I'm trying to get a little bit more of a
head start than I did last year CU I
waited until this album had come out and
like months passed and then I and so I
would like it to coincide a little bit
more so you can pre-order having not
even heard all of the songs you can
pre-order the album and I'm also trying
to make it where you can and um I'm
promising a lot you got a lot going on
uh I'm trying to make it where you you
get a digital download of the songs when
you buy it but it won't come out until
release day so just because people asked
for that last time anyway that's the I'm
just taking this opportunity to promote
it because it's a song about you that
I'm very very very happy with you're
using me get it and I went out into the
Wilderness and I recorded myself singing
that song about you and I actually for
this one I think I did a pretty good job
I actually actually sing it good so I'm
GNA actually show that instead of just
showing all the
fails this was fun this was fun remember
if you would like to make a comment ask
a question you can do that by calling
our line we have a line 1888 Ear Pod one
you can only say nice things though
that's right that's how that line works
I mean I think most of the things are
nice but that is not a requirement but
it is if you're I think it should be a
requirement Jesse's making that a
requirement only say nice that's right
only sweet only sweet things uh and keep
the conversation online with #
earbiscuits we like to know even though
Twitter is slowly dying uh we do like
you to still have conversations about
ear biscuits in places like that #
earbiscuits hey R link this is me and my
me John and my wife kimy we uh went on
vacation to North Carolina topa Island
and we decided to make a pass through
buoy Creek uh you know
for you any who hope you guys are doing
awesome and I love you guys I love what
you're doing awesome
bye to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of ear biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the cirular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical
best